it's been frustrating and i thought well
it'll never reach audiences maybe
but now it's going to in canada so i'm
so happy because that's where we shot it
and
we had a great canadian crew seem well
rested after your nap this afternoon
does that always help help what your
memory
in falling vigo plays a middle-aged man
whose father starts showing signs of
dementia
forcing him to move in with his son and
son-in-law
what kind of doctor is your boyfriend
he's my husband
he's not a doctor he's a nurse you know
that you know when you're writing this
film and you have an actor and mine was
lance henriksen someone that was kind of
at the top of your list he's amazing
in the movie it's a really complex
sometimes disturbing
very honest portrayal this movie
wouldn't be what it is without him
obviously
and for vigo who also wrote directed and
produced the drama
the story is a personal one as well i
was thinking i guess
in some ways feelings and memories i had
from my childhood because it's
sort of relates to my parents in some
ways even though it's a fictional family
and to dementia you know because i
experienced that with my parents and
grandparents lots of
my stepfather up close and so i put that
into
lance's character evan doesn't want him
and he'll keep sending him back
david cronenberg um he has this amazing
cameo in this film what was it like
you know kind of turning the tables and
directing him for once
it was a lot of fun it was a great
experience and shooting in canada
obviously canadian crew
when he walked in the room onto the set
it was you know
it was it was exciting it was fun when
you know you worked with someone like
david cronenberg what do you learn from
him
that you took into your role as a
director on a family falling
what i've learned from the best
directors and i was thinking of him
among others
is that a good idea can come from
anybody at any time so
bring it on don't don't hesitate